jean-vincent placé le président du
groupe des douze sénateurs écologistes l
invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir
et bienvenue émission à trois temps bien
sûr avec l' agence france-presse
représenter ce soir par katell prison et
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
l'application tivi tchèque d'orange
permet toujours aux téléspectateurs de
réagir durant ce rendez vous jean
vincent placé jean marc ayrault fait
sortir l'opposition de ses gonds et même
de l'hémicycle d'ailleurs de l'assemblée
nationale lors des questions d'actualité
vous avez vu ça il a affirmé que la
droite veut l'échec de la france est-ce
que c'est également votre sentiment
je pense que le premier ministre a eu un
propos adaptées au comportement
incroyable de l'opposition depuis quatre
mois critiquant tout ne faisant aucune
proposition justement pour le pays
manifestement englué dans les débats
internes à l'ump et avec une mémoire
externe extrêmement courte dix ans de
gouvernement
cinq ans avec sarkozy la faillite du
pays un million de chômeurs
supplémentaires 600 milliards de dettes
supplémentaires à dire aujourd'hui
qu'elle veut l'échec de la france
composition mais c'est un mot c'est un
mort un propos qui en plus correspond je
crois à un temps qui est celui de la
séance des questions au gouvernement où
on a l'impression que ces parlementaires
d'ailleurs ils sont beaucoup plus calmes
au sénat mais c'est députés à
l'assemblée nationale sont là au théâtre
dans l'invectivé parfois même dans
l'injure on l'a vu le comportement
misogyne est incroyable avec cécile
duflot on entend des propos de café du
commerce et c'est vrai que cela
discrédite beaucoup la position et donc
n'attendait pas à l'interpellation sur
l'échec de la france que audrey
l'opposition de droite selon le premier
ministre prend le premier ministre il
est excédé de cela je crois que c'est un
premier ministre qui travaille beaucoup
qui est sérieux solide et qui ont fait
le projet gouvernemental avec sa
majorité parlementaire donc vous voyez
je suis un soutien du premier ministre a
commencé aussi bien pour le président le
premier ministre et les ministres là
dans la situation très dure que nous
vivons justement par rapport au bilan de
l'équipe précédente
et bien c'est pas facile donc quand il
ya des désaccords y'a pas de soucis vous
le savez c'est bon ils sont sur la table
aussi dans la franchise la sincérité
mais la fondation c'est que le soutien
soutien est là aussi fidèle et loyal
parce que justement nous nous occupons
du pays d'aucuns évoquent un climat
social qui pourrait se tendre puisque la
situation économique est très mauvaises
le chômage va continuer à empirer mois
après mois et une situation qui pourrait
conduire à des élections anticipées
imagine certain que pensez vous de ce
scénario
non mais c'est tout cela est ridicule on
est dans une politique fiction qui n'a
pas de sens cela fait depuis mais que ce
gouvernement est en place
il a fait beaucoup de choses en fait
team ctr on a déjà mis en bouche les
trous déjà rade des dettes qui avait été
accumulé par l'équipe précédente et au
lieu d'imposer les plus modestes et puis
d'exonérer les plus riches et bien nous
on fait l'inversé est assez simple quand
même et nous sommes la combative tout à
la fois sur les politiques économiques
les politiques sociales c'est pas facile
évidemment vous l'avez indiqué compris
j'aurai des choses à dire sur le manque
de vision écologique du gouvernement la
perspective quand même encore trop
modeste par rapport à transition
énergétique et écologique
mais voilà c'est difficile et mal à
manier l'art vous défendez le premier
minitsre d'ibm laquelle est posée non
mais c'est votre histoire présence
d'alice anticipé au bout de cinq mois
sans ridicule ya une représentation qui
a été élu d'accord la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale est clair nous
avons là n'a toujours pas toujours débat
il ya des débats et nous ne sommes pas
pour la majorité godillot on voit où six
où cela a mené ce qu'il faut faire cette
fidèle et loyal voilà c'est important
vous voyez que nous sommes
mais il ya aussi les choses on n'est pas
d'accord on l'a dit sous traités
européens
on le dira aussi dans le débat sur la
loi de finance par rapport à
aux thèmes qui nous sont chères sur les
niches fiscales écolo sur les thèmes qui
sont ce les emplois verts voilà on a
beaucoup de thèmes que nous voulons voir
avec plus de dynamisme et plus d'entrain
et de volontarisme par cette majorité
accord mais en revanche voilà et son
aspect politiciens des élections
anticipées et sur les critiques de
l'opposition franchement qu'ils fassent
une proposition si vous vous êtes
capable de me dire ce qu'ils ont fait
comme proposition de piquette mois voilà
bon d'accord vous avez défendu premier
ministre sa solidité mais je vois
ségolène royal qui estime que maintenant
le temps est venu pour le gouvernement
et le président d'ailleurs de fixer un
cap leucate vous le voyez vous certains
je voyage je crois qu est ce qui est
important effectivement c'est d'indiquer
que le temps y compris des fameuses la
bible des 60 propositions
le temps est quasiment passé c'est vrai
ça va tellement vite que le gros de ces
éléments de propositions sont en place y
compris moi je salue la banque publique
d'investissement même s'il ya beaucoup
d'autres choses à faire et peut-être
encore plus vite et puis avec aussi plus
d'argent il faut dire les choses très
clairement et plus orientée vers les
questions écologiques mais je crois que
dans la perspective qui vient oui il
nous faut une grande réforme notamment
une grande réforme fiscale
je crois qu'il est extrêmement important
on avait mis en avant la question de la
fusion par exemple de l'impôt sur le
revenu et la csg
je pense que c'est toujours d'actualité
j'écoutais l'autre jour les économistes
et fiscalistes piketty et qui de tracer
une perspective qui avait été longtemps
d'ailleurs un des conseillers du parti
socialiste avant l'élection hélas
aujourd'hui sur la fiscalité la réforme
c'est à mon avis trop frileux et donc il
faut aller vers plus de choses là dessus
sur la conversion écologique de
l'économie j'en ai parlé il nous faut
beaucoup plus de moyens parce que la
banque publique d'investissement par
exemple doit devenir cette banque la
transition écologique
qu'appelle de ses voeux nicolas hulot et
nous aussi bien sûr et là il nous faut
des moyens
nous en proposons la suppression des
niches fiscales entier colo sur le le p6
des pesticides sur les agrocarburants
sur le diesel sur le kérosène il y à là
près de 20 milliards d'euros qui
permettrait tout à la fois de changer
notre fiscalité fiscalité écologique est
tout à la fois de réorienter des
comportements industriels économiques
lait de consommation et enfin troisième
point je pense qu'elle est extrêmement
important c'est que
moi j'ai écouté les propositions qui
sont faites sur la réforme territoriale
sur l'acte iii décentralisation
attention à ne pas faire trop de
frilosité encore c'est à dire qu'en ce
moment on sent que grande partie des
propositions du président république ont
été déjà mises en oeuvre ou vont être
mises en oeuvre ces chantiers là
effectivement en termes de cap en terme
de stratégie il y ait un débat cette
stratégie là je dis réforme fiscale vers
plus de la justice la question
écologique et bien sûr la question des
réformes territoriales extrêmement
important parce que en france
aujourd'hui c'est grâce aux régions
c'est grâce aux agglomérations métropole
que nous pourrons créer les emplois et
apporter une dynamique aujourd'hui et
qui n'est pas là bien sûr et pas au
département que vous voudriez voir
disparaître petit à petit on a déjà
parlé un jeu reste assez
vous avez cité cécile duflot qui a subi
quelques assauts de l'opposition au
début un de ses fonctions de ministre du
logement mais alors dites moi c'est peu
de chose par rapport aux revers qu'on
lui annonce avec le conseil
constitutionnel qui va retoqué sa loi
sur le logement social au sein de vous
savez demain la décision 9 chances sur
10 qu'elle soit retoquée alors et vous
vous êtes parlementaire tout va être mis
à bas parce qu'elle n'a pas respecté le
délai non des débats au sénat
cécile duflot ministre du logement elle
avait préparé très bien préparé cette
loi pendant tout l'été c'est c'était
prévu pour être discutée fin septembre
juste après les semaines des journées
parlementaires des différents groupes
politiques
on se souvient très bien une décision a
été prise à haut niveau 1 d'anticiper
cette session parlementaire avec une
session extraordinaire
moi je vais être franc avec vous je
n'étais pas particulièrement favorable
je l'avais indiqué aux intéressés et
voilà où pourrait nous mener 7
un couac l'énorme cette anticipation des
précipités session parlementaire je
n'allais c'est vous qui avez des
précipitations vous constatez que moi
j'ai dit anticipations je suis attentif
au vocabulaire est à la mesure du
auger et et je pense que la prochaine
fois et ce n'est pas pour me cécile
duflot je dis cela parce que ce n'était
pas elle qui maîtrise la chandelle à
l'ordre du jour bien évidemment l'ordre
du jour du gouvernement et assumera son
malheur par le gouvernement et je le dis
par votre chef et à partir du moment où
cette session était anticipée et ce à
deux doigts donner des leçons pour
l'avenir c'est à dire que ces leçons
pour l'avenir c'est de faire attention
au temps parlementaire et moins six
présidents de groupes parlementaires
choisir je suis particulièrement
attentifs à la revalorisation qui ne
veut pas dire lenteur mais qui veut dire
du débat voilà donc si je vous entends
bien jean vincent placé si le conseil
constitutionnel rend caduque cette loi
qui a été votée et bien ça ne sera pas
la faute de cécile duflot est sûr que
non elle sera une victime c'est surtout
le logement qui en est victime mais ça
je crois que il faudra faire vite pour
revoter en respectant les délais
parlementaire mais attendons quand même
la décision dès demain si vous aussi
bien sûr nous attendons mais on connaît
déjà vos arguments de défense donc de
votre muse il résulte selon la vérité
tout simplement parce que je peux vous
dire que les groupes parlementaires de
la majorité lorsque la décision a été
prise à haut niveau comme je l'indiquais
je crois qu'aucun d'entre nous n'étions
accords est content on se rend compte
jour après jour que la majorité est très
difficile à trouver au sénat sur un
certain nombre de dossiers risquent
d'ailleurs ce qui vous donnent un poids
important ici un comme d'ailleurs les
radicaux de gauche et comme leurs
munitions ils sont aujourd'hui à
l'initiative d'une motion
d'irrecevabilité qui a été voté avec
d'ailleurs quelques voix venues du parti
socialiste au sujet de ce texte sur le
bonus malus énergétique double prenez
ces jolies l'homme voit je vous
l'apprends effectivement la calvitie
signalé rue bellevue absolument on vient
de l'apprendre votre action je crois que
dans cette
proposition de loi qui a été déjà
débattu à l'assemblée qui a été voté il
faut être franc je vais très franc je
crois que par plus grand monde ne
comprend vraiment quelle est
l'orientation générale de cette
proposition nous les écologistes sont
extrêmement favorables
évidemment à l'idée initiale de la
tarification progressive de ce qu'on
appelle les biens communs pour nous et
notamment l'électricité
donc voilà il fallait s'organiser pour
faire en sorte que changer les
comportements
on lutte contre le gaspillage on fasse
attention aussi aux plus modestes et à
la fin évidemment c'est un jeu de mots
bien facile et bien répandu ça commence
à devenir une usine à gaz et nous mêmes
c'est vrai à l'assemblée nous avons voté
seule d'ailleurs avec le parti
socialiste
et là dans la navette nous nous sommes
aperçus je crois que tout le monde s'est
aperçu qu'il fallait rediscuter avec
l'ensemble des acteurs aussi bien les
entrepreneurs que les usagers que les
syndicalistes et moi je ne sais pas du
tout nos propres sur nos amis
communistes parce que quelque part quand
il ya des majorités de circonstance
comme cela entre le parti communiste et
la droite ce n'est pas scandaleux en soi
c'est que ça veut dire que venant de
deux formations politiques totalement
différente on arrive à une même réponse
de procédure et ça veut dire donc il
faut rediscuter davantage et moi
j'appelle notre ami et collègue brottes
ainsi que le gouvernement à rediscuter
rapidement avec l'ensemble des
composantes bien sûr les socialistes et
écologistes mais aussi avec le parti
communiste français
moi je ne travaillons très bien avec
eliane assassi et s'il en est arrivé
avec son groupe a à faire cela c'est que
déjà elle est s interroge sur le mode de
discussion avec le gouvernement il faut
être très attentif à ça ça me
revaloriser le rôle du parlement ça
montre bien que le gouvernement a du mal
avec le fait il a c'est une majorité
impossible à trouver pour lui alors il
s'est il ya il a une majorité social
enfants passe à la droite écologistes
corps fois grâce à vos corps clérical de
gauche avec majorité elle est derrière
jean pierre bel notre président qui est
un excellent président de l'avis de
toutes et tous nous travaillons très
bien avec les différents groupes
politiques
après il ya les prises de position c'est
normal moi je vais vous dire on essaie
parfois de dire mais on a des querelles
avec les radicaux de gauche
on n'a pas de querelles en soit et
radicaux de gauche il s'avère que
le groupe radical est particulièrement
pro nucléaire par exemple ici bon on
n'est pas d'accord mais c'est son droit
de penser cela s'est pas encore interdit
et bien dans leur lorsqu'il ya des
débats soient énergie forcément n'est
pas forcément on est toujours sur les
mac avec la d'accord vous n'avez rien
contre la compétitivité vous avez dit
que vous vouliez réorienter la fiscalité
pour changer les comportements mais vous
pourriez aussi réorienter la fiscalité
moi je suis plutôt pour alléger les
charges sur le travail oui ou non je
suis plutôt pour la coopération et le
vélo partenariat et je constate que
évidemment comme tout le monde il ya des
insuffisances très criante de
l'industrie et particulièrement à
l'exportation mais je constate aussi
qu'à chaque fois la même petite musique
c'est de dire il faut réduire ce que
certains appellent les charges sociales
mois que j'appelle des cotisations mais
je crois pas du tout que ce soit le bon
chemin
d'ailleurs le présent la république à
châlons-en-champagne rappelé que le coût
du travail chez nous ou en allemagne
était à peu près similaires et que
justement la vision industrielle
d'avenir pour la coopération et le
partenariat avec les autres pays pour y
compris avoir des parts de marchés
utiles sont des bons produits
c'est d'être utile sur de nouveaux
produits à plus forte valeur ajoutée
plus moderne et plus encore dans quelle
philosophie moi je m'inscrive de
philosophie donc il n'est pas celle de
louis gallois qui lui prône un
abaissement des charges des cotisations
sociales pour l'alléger le coût du
travail on va en parler dans un instant
et monsieur je vous annonce et
constitutionnelles y rend son rapport à
novembre ce qu'on sait en revanche ce
qu'on sait mars il ya des fuites dans un
journal d'accord proche de la droite
le voilà dans le figaro qui a
effectivement levé le voile peut être
pour mieux enterrer rapidement ce
rapport plus milan bari embarrasser le
gouvernement qui semble l'être en tous
les cas toujours est il que delphine
batho la ministre de l'environnement a
confirmé elle qu'elle avait eu un
échange aigre-doux avec le gallois sur
deux sujets le nucléaire et les gaz de
schiste puisque louis gallois est
favorable aux deux alors on va être un
instant si vous voulez bien jean vincent
placé écologiquement incorrects
imaginons ensemble les bienfaits du gaz
de schiste pour notre économie en panne
joachim robe pour certains c'est un
trésor qui dort dans notre sous sol et
dont on se prive pour de mauvaises
raisons
pour d'autres dont le gouvernement le
gaz de schiste présente trop d'inconnues
pour la santé et l'environnement
son exploitation reste donc
interdite en france mais certains
souhaitent rouvrir le débat ça permettra
notamment de réduire les importations
donc d'améliorer la balance commerciale
française puis deuxièmement si on
entendre suffisamment ça permettra
d'avoir un pouvoir de négociation de
discussions avec les fournisseurs
extérieurs et donc peut-être là on met y
aurait une possible baisse du prix du
gaz non négligeable à l'heure où la
france importe 98 % de sa consommation
reste un autre argument c'est créerait
de l'emploi l'activité
parce que pour exploiter ces gaz de
schiste il faut il faut des tuyauteries
faut des traitements tout à quelque
chose dans lesquels les entreprises
françaises soient appliquées un argument
balayé par cette journaliste
indépendante co auteur d'une enquête sur
le gaz de schiste c'est des emplois qui
sont peu qualifiés pas si nombreux que
ça et surtout sur une période de temps
très courte cd ou one shot on fore et
puis on extrait au bout de quatre ans le
puits la sec et qui ont par les
territoires eux ils vont rester avec les
conséquences environnementales pour
l'instant une seule technique existe la
fracturation hydraulique qui impactent
fortement l'environnement mais la
recherche pourrait permettre de trouver
d'autres méthodes de forage ou mais
peut-être assis sur des réserves
colossales étudions regardons analysons
et partageons des résultats mais ne
rejetons pas brutalement une technologie
sans l'avoir examinée sans l'avoir
analysé sans l'avoir étudiée preuve que
le débat n'est pas définitivement
enterré les premiers membres de la
commission de suivi des gaz de schiste
créé il ya plus d'un an viennent d'être
nommés jean-vincent placé le plaisir
d'accueillir pour la première fois sur
ce plateau ce soir notre consoeur de l'
agence france-presse
qu'at-elle présent bonsoir vos questions
donc au président du groupe écologiste
du sénat ayant justement le gaz de
schiste on viens de l'entendre débat
n'est pas enterré d'autant plus que
selon la presse le rapport aux gallois
sur la compétivité vite et remet aussi
le gage de schiste dans le débat il
faudrait pas un débat vraiment public
est autorisé
on débat de ce sujet depuis
deux ans c'est sur la table d'ailleurs
on voit l'acharnement du lobby du gaz de
schiste qui est je le dise on le
présente partout très actif depuis
trois-quatre mois déjà dans les cabinets
ministériels auprès de bercy de matignon
voilà donc je constate qu'effectivement
ça c'est une musique qui ai compris a
été reprise par le ministre de
l'industrie monsieur montebourg qui a
été arbitrée par le premier ministre qui
a été arbitré également par le président
la république à conférence
environnementale mais nous les
écologistes nous ne faisons pas sur
l'argument d'autorité du polizario
public même si je la respecte c'est nous
on est dans le débat et le débat c'est
que il suffit de montrer parce que ça
vous ne l'avez pas fait dans votre
excellent reportage c'est que c'est de
voir de quoi il s'agit à deux trois
mille 4000 mètres sous le sol
enfin petit tunnel ensuite on fait à
l'horizontale et on balance
tranquillement à côté des nappes
phréatiques et dans l'environnement et
dans la la biodiversité des millions de
mètres cubes d'eau de sable et de
produits chimiques et de l'avis général
c'est extrêmement nuisible à notre
environnement à notre santé et c'est
très préjudiciable et d'ailleurs ça a
été même repris par nos amis de la
droite il ose dire parce que quand
christian jacob a vu ça se passait chez
lui en seine-et-marne et qu' il y avait
non pas seulement les écologistes mais
des gens de sa circonscription très
énervé par rapport est très inquiet en
réalité au delà de la petite boutade ils
sont trés il était très inquiet devant
sa permanence
il avait à l'époque légiférait en
laissant une porte ouverte évidemment
comme d'habitude on est un petit peu
d'ambiguïté voir d'hypocrisie dans cette
affaire et nous nous avons fermé cette
possibilité a sous l'autorité du présent
république on voit bien en plus et ça a
été dit par la personne dans le
reportage que y compris la question
industrielle économique et du coup n'est
pas du tout étudié pour l'instant n'ont
ils pas sur la table
c'est étudié par aux états unis
notamment
et on voit que c'est une filière ces
états unis où justement gros succès
quand même
grosjean qui brisent rapatriés qui
reviennent dans ses exploitations donc
gros succès économique
non pas du tout parce que justement
lorsqu'on voit le coût d'investissement
et le coup de rentabilité ça on n'y est
pas réellement alors comme évidemment il
ya une vision d'anticipation du futur on
se dit on va réussir à prendre des parts
de marché c'est pour ça que ça devient
aussi vital pour certains d'arriver dans
l'hexagone ou semblerait-il
effectivement il y aurait des gisements
importants de gaz et d'huile de schiste
est bien dans cette vision
expansionniste oui peut-être il pourrait
y avoir ce débat là mais c'est vraiment
faire fi de tout ce qui a été dit
d'ailleurs pendant le grenelle de
l'environnement qui interdit et produits
totalement seul genre en afrique c'est
interdit l'afrique mais il ya six ont
trouvé une autre solution pour pourrir
il y en a pas c'est comme si vous me
disiez on va faire du nucléaire sans
déchets voilà c'est fait pas confiance
aux scientifiques aux chercheurs qui
mais moi je vais le moyen d'extraction
de cette richesse où nos passes moi je
suis comme saint thomas je crois ce que
je vois et lorsqu'il y aura eu un débat
réel avec les scientifiques et qu'on
pourra y compris et un voire des
expérimentations qui se ferait non pas
directement mais en projection et bien
pourquoi pas mais là il est hors de
question pour nous de nouveau rentrer
dans ce débat là et je vous dis tous les
deux mois trois mois on a encore le
débat qui vient monsieur gallois est là
dedans je déplore vous comprenez que
c'est un peu compliqué pour les gens
dont on ne dira qu'à une richesse sous
nos pieds alors qu'on leur demande de se
serrer la ceinture et donc on peut pas
on peut même pas en débattre on peut pas
en parler à chaque fois on dit non toute
façon c'est réglé tout le monde on débat
on voit bien que notion de boer gérer un
peu par ailleurs est moins bien que nos
amis de l'industrie énergétique sont
très présents où on a vu le silence je
crois ce n'était pas vrai mais qui le le
patron justement de l'union des
industries de l'énergie
tous les mois dans l'humain parce qu'il
ne veut pas vous provoquez j'ai
l'impression que j'ai fait un débat avec
les effectivement elle avait trouvé
assez prudent sur la question lui fait
peur non non pas du tout mais je pense
que justement il a lui aussi les
différentes études du conseil général du
développement durable et d'autres
organismes qui ne sont pas
particulièrement
ouverte sur la question et qui
considèrent que d'une part en terme de
coût cela serait pas tout à fait quelque
chose de très compétitif et d'autre part
le coût environnemental j'ai indiqué il
paraît qu'en l'instant très flagrant non
mais pas pour l'instant c'est comme
toujours elle présidera un public déjà
et c'est l'on dit que pendant le
quinquennat n'y aurait pas deux ans de
permis octroyés autre sujet où
décidément monsieur la loi va être pas
être votre ami c'est que deuxième
richesse de la france selon lui enfin ce
lorsque ce qui pourrait être révélé dans
son rapport c'est le nucléaire oui c'est
la totale une vieille lune comme dit
votre ami monsieur d'origine mais c'est
bon moi j'ai pas envie de dire du mal de
monsieur gallois parce que c'est
quelqu'un je respecte beaucoup
après aux 40 80 il était déjà le dr kane
et jean pierre chevènement bonbons qu'il
a de la constance dans ses idées c'est
un haut fonctionnaire comme la france
ont produit des remarquables et il fait
partie de ceux là il a ensuite présidé
des entreprises nationales nommé en
conseil des ministres un après avoir été
aux fonctionnaires nommés dans
l'industrie ou la d'ailleurs très bien
réussi par exemple je pense à la sncf où
il est resté dix ans c'est au son des
entreprises publiques de service public
mais voilà je ne veux pas désagréable
même s'il ya eu des ads il a fait le
travail etc
mais quelle est la légitimité que on
peut avoir parce qu'on a été haut
fonctionnaire et non parce que ça plante
industrielle1 voilà c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est qu'en france mais je suis
content qu'on ait de débat en france on
dit c'est un grand industriel
oui non c'est un haut fonctionnaire qui
a été chef d'entreprise et nommée mais
la vision industrielle c'est quoi c'est
d'essayer de créer une nouvelle activité
un nouveau produit d'aller à l'export
non non il y en a une vision on en
europe le vrai et c'est ce qu'on vous
disait tout à l'heure par paquet sur la
compétitivité moi j'ai dédie d'ailleurs
se fait parfois râler le vrai problème
du pays depuis longtemps c'est peut-être
une des formes d'industrie colbertiste
c'est à dire que tout à la fois on est
sur des sujets assez tradi conservateurs
c'est le nucléaire on se dit voilà c'est
l'idée du gaz de schiste
au lieu de ça on pourrait faire les
énergies renouvelables on pourrait faire
la rénovation de bâtiments mais ça ça
fait rigoler parce qu'on se dit ah bah
non c'est parce qu'on faisait
traditionnellement esterra sauf que les
allemands ils ont fait 381 mille emplois
au danemark en chine évidemment en corée
du sud les etats-unis sont très
largement en avance sur nous et nous on
reste sur le schéma habituel ou
d'ailleurs les hauts fonctionnaires il
faut ensuite de l'industrie comme vous
dites on dit un grand industriel bon
même si j'ai pas de critiques à faire 12
ou alors ce sont des banquiers c'est
monsieur jouyet jeu moi j'ai du respect
c'est pas moi duo de malouda lui résume
à l expérience industrielle et connais
mal je vais mais le gallois mais le
système français de la pensée unique
tradi qui paraît authentifié par les
grandes écoles typé n'a franchement moi
j'en ai marre c'est aussi pour ça que ce
pays est extrêmement immobile et frileux
notamment d'un compétition
internationale et c'est la même histoire
jean pierre jouyet bien sûr qu'il est
super intelligent jean-pierre juillet
bien sûr qu'il a plein d'idées bien sûr
qui c'est tout il a même été mise
affaires européennes de sarkozy vont
très bien mais là on le met à la caisse
des dépôts on le met à la bpi
mais on est avec bientôt qu'elle mettra
banque de france et au crédit immobilier
de france enfin voilà allons chercher
moi j'ai pas d'idée d'assu particulière
mais d'aider des jeunes qui veulent se
lancer qui diamé non mais est ce que
vous voyez que on est un pays où la
plupart des des commissions comme mon
trophée sac lionel jospin et c'est pas
une question d'âge à fin mai sur la vie
politique
on fait ensuite gallois enfin voilà aux
états unis voyez il ya un débat romney
obama non mais il ya des bars ont mené
au bras on va bientôt être dans les
divisions du parti communiste chinois ou
à la fin au yen reproduction des élites
ce sont les mêmes en tout genre c'est
pour ça que ce rapport est franchement
je moi j'ai peur j'ai du respect
évidemment pour partir et quand même
vous les verrez pour l'hiver les noms
mais quand même
jouyet
je souhaite vraiment que nos
téléspectateurs réfléchissent à ça mais
vous les avez donc habillé pour l'hiver
et au delà les écologistes on a parfois
une critique sur notre crédibilité etc
on est dit ah bah oui mais vous venez
d'où vous idée mais nos idées sont
bonnes et nos idées et s'applique déjà
dans le monde entier
on a du retard non non non non non ça
arrive franchement je suis bien occupé
en ce moment donc tout va bien
mais voilà ces idées-là de la conversion
écologique de l'économie de la modernité
ne pas essayer d'être dans le débat
nommé six ans rapport du sein qui doit
sortir 5 novembre
eh bien il ya quand même l'idée de
baisser cotisations pour faire réduire
des dépenses publiques et augmenter la
csg à la tva de près de 10 milliards
c'est à dire à peu près l'équivalent de
scorer rapporté la tva sociale du
gouvernement précédent
très simplement la prochaine foire au
lieu de faire le rapport ils monsieur
gallois on le fait que monsieur baroin
madame pécresse soit là ce serait à peu
près le même rapport alors on vous
résume jean vincent placé a lors du
ballet non mais voilà c'est dit c'est
dit autant venir grossir à nom n'est pas
4e non non non juste un joli aux gallois
les objets qui vous qui vous plaît un
peu plus et professeur séralini
malheureusement son étude
je récuse et donc l'étude est accusé de
nouveau donc les ogm de nouveau de
nouveau en débat non mais c'est ce
n'était pas plus pertinent avec l'étude
que son l'étude
nous nous attirons l'attention avec le
principe de précaution sur la nocivité
des ogm et le fait qu' il y en ait
aujourd'hui avec la réglementation
européenne
partout dans les produits alimentaires y
compris de nos enfants voilà donc on a
eu des débats cours sur lesquels on a
été les précurseurs les lanceurs
d'alerté d'où d'ailleurs proposition de
loi que nous voulons faire sur le sujet
avec par écrit c'est mme blandin nous
nous voulons l'indépendance deux
expertises
on veut pas avoir quelqu'un qui pousse
un peu le trait sur une étude tout seul
dans un pour faire des coups médiatiques
et on veut pas non plus les labos payer
disons-le par des groupes industriels
dont je donnerai pas de nom pour ne pas
discourtois mais ça existe et donc au
milieu il doit y avoir des structures
d'indépendance et cette indépendance
permettra de faire des réels des études
qui pourront nous attirer vers principe
de précaution davantage attirer
l'attention au niveau de la commission
européenne où beaucoup de choses se
passent
et voilà nous nous sommes nous très
opposés à la culture en plein champ vous
le savez parce qu'il ya des risques de
dissémination
nous ne sommes pas avec la lampe à huile
parce que nous sommes pour la recherche
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de risque et en
revanche tant qu'on n'a pas une
expertise indépendante et bâle
la quiétude et la rue la précaution
donnons les jeux je discute avec le
recul je vous appartenez serait plus de
temps vous dire lorsque vous voyez une
présence ogm sur le maïs ou d'aix où je
suis sûr vous prenez une autre boîte a
lâché sur vous prenez pas la boîte oui
c'est marqué ogm assure que c'est un
argument commercial très bon et sauf que
avec la réglementation parce qu'ils les
lobbys sont très malins ils se glissent
c'est quand c'est à moins de 0 1% et
bien du produit eh bien il peut y avoir
des objets il y en a partout il y en a
dans les céréales dans les produits
alimentaires plats cuisinés etc
moi j'ai regardé ça une minute pour la
dernière question est votre dernière
réponse à cappelle prigent
granier nom dont on a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers temps du flore ensemble à huy
l'élu du xiiie qui est mise en examen
dans une affaire de blanchiment
du balai non non je crois que pascal
durand notre état national a communiqué
sur le sujet et il a été très clair bon
sens la menthe et enfin vendu ses
mandats vous dit tout sans jeter
d'opprobre parce que bon c'était et
c'est toujours je crois une camarade de
parti après le blanchiment je ne sais
pas moi je ne suis pas juge je suis pas
procureur non plus
il ya des reconnaissances de faits de
fraude fiscale et il ya eu en eux sont
de tirer c'est de tout à la fois de se
défendre dans la présomption d'innocence
qui n'a pas été vraiment respectée et
puis de se démettre de ses mandats et je
vais vous taquinez encore parce que vous
voyez je suis en forme
on allait enfin j'espère et j'y
travaille faire en sorte qu'on puisse
mettre en place une loi ou lorsque un
jour je sais pas ce cas là mais parce
que la peine est déjà là avec les médias
pendant 72 heures on est coupable
pendant une semaine on est coupable mon
propos est plus général que ce qu'elle
raconte je vois énormément de cas où on
met les gens au pilori sur la place
publique et qu'en deux ans plus tard il
ya un non lieu je parle pas de ces cas
là mais c'est j'attire l'attention y
compris des médias par rapport à des
ontologies je vous parle même plus du
secret d'instruction puisque l'on n'est
plus là je parle même pas du nombre des
travaux proposé l'application est bien
de faire en sorte que si il ya des non
lieux
eh bien on est le même temps de
communication aux mêmes heures
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour
innocence et d un malheur pour les bien
sûr merci katell prigent mais elle est
bien on y verrait très bien où on en
parlerait on verra on n'a pas le temps
d'en débattre c'est la vôtre
allez on va revenir sur le rôle que vous
jouez donc avec votre groupe de douze
sénateurs écologistes on en a déjà un
petit peu parlé tout à l'heure jean
vincent placé a un rôle clé bien sûr
avec celui des radicaux de gauche des
communistes et je le rappelle puisque
donc les socialistes n'ont pas la
majorité au sénat joue va presque
sourire jean vincent placé avant
d'accueillir perrine tarneaud un
éclairage signé bérengère d'ingrats
maillon manquant de la majorité
lorsqu'on entend cette petite phrase on
se dit qu'elle s'adresse sans aucun
doute aux verts alliés plutôt remuant et
pas toujours très fiable de la majorité
présidentielle que nenni comble de
l'ironie c'est au contraire les verts
eux mêmes qui critiquent ainsi leurs
alliés radicaux en s'abstenant
ils ont empêché une résolution
écologistes favorable lors d'être votée
nous nous sommes là pour appuyer la
politique du président de la république
et du premier ministre
ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous soyons
des supplétifs de l'armée qui serait à
moins de herne des routes mais nous ne
faisons pas de surenchère
car jusqu'ici question solidarité
gouvernementale
les verts n'ont pas trop de leçons à
donner il y a quelques semaines le refus
de voter le traité européen est apparu
comme le premier couac de la majorité
gouvernementale
aujourd'hui encore le parti n'hésite pas
à critiquer ouvertement la politique du
président de la république
globalement et bien se dessinent pas une
politique stratégie pour faire face à la
crise déçu désabusés les verts en croire
pascal durand ce matin dans le figaro
il souffre de l'arrogance des barons du
ps ainsi à l'assemblée barbara pompili
et son co président du groupe verts
n'ont toujours pas eu de réunion de
coordination avec leur homologue
socialiste bruno le roux
pour le porte-parole du parti une petite
leçon de loyauté vous savez il ya
en russie quelque chose qui s'appelle la
troïka la troïka c'est finalement un
attelage avec deux types de chevaux des
chevaux qui sont au galop et des chevaux
qui sont tous trop bas notre pacte
majoritaire c'est aussi une troïka
aujourd'hui nous on est au galop
derrière le gouvernement
et pour l'instant ils sont ou trop bas
on attend qu'il passe ou qui aimeraient
bien passer au galop pour probable enfin
vraiment définitivement ancré le pacte
majoritaire
si l assemblée les verts sont snobés par
leurs collègues socialistes au sénat
l'état d'esprit est un peu différent peu
nombreux
12 sur 348 ils parviennent pourtant à
faire beaucoup parler d'eux le président
du groupe jean vincent placé est partout
presse écrite et les depuis un an
l'élu de l'essonne irrite souvent mais
son activisme s'avère plutôt efficace
s'il devait retenir un adjectif pour
décrire jean vincent placé celles
habilitées peuvent que je retiendrai
entre le besoin identitaire et la
culture de gouvernement les verts vont
devoir choisir la phase de rodage ne
s'éternisera pas et l'avenir de la
majorité gouvernementale est en jeu
quand vous allez passer au galop si on
écoute bien quand il est membre aux
gallois déjà on a compris pas aux
gallois
bon et puis quand on vous entend aussi
critiqué les radicaux de gauche ici
sénat voulait traiter de maillon
manquant dans la majorité la simple
l'hôpital qui suis-je et la charité non
jean vincent placé nouveau entre deux
personnes moi je suis même un communiqué
we do mécontentement après
le rejet d'une proposition de résolution
très solide et argumentée qui était
présenté en particulier mme aline
archimbaud sénatrice de la seine saint
denis qui reprenait qui consolider
l'accord qui avait été indiqué par jean
marc ayrault le premier ministre le
parti socialiste un groupe socialiste
avait voté d'autres
ppr proposition de parlementaires de
résolution est on réellement des
meetings résidentiel d'être des parties
goody enfin c'est pas une question de
godillots c'est que c'était une
proposition de résolution qui soutenait
plus locaux la politique du gouvernement
qui a porté des lunettes et morcellement
toujours là au rendez vous toujours 13
ans nous nous sommes fait peur avec
le gouvernement et le président de la
république d'une part on a voté pour
évidemment qu'un président soit élu
nous sommes dans la majorité
parlementaire nous avons un accord et
cet accord est important et nous nous
voulons faire respecter après dans le
débat nous avions sorti vous le savez le
pack budgétaire européen parce que pour
le coup on ne voyait pas comment il
pourrait y avoir de compromis
nous avons eu notre vote essentiellement
négatif est sur la trajectoire
budgétaire vous constaterez que ce n'est
pas pour embêter gouvernement d'ailleurs
de grandes voix commencent à dire qu'on
tiendra pas et 3% en 2013 celle de
pascal durand le leader libyen parce
qu'elles dureront bien sûr mais il ya
aussi aux clauses bien cerner cet
objectif on note que certains le
président l'assemblée nationale yahia
harlem désir et même pierre moscovici
mais économie et des finances a commencé
à ouvrir la porte
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un moment il ya
la réalité moi je crois que c'est
extrêmement important d'être
volontariste et enthousiaste y compris
sur la politique industrielle pour aller
chercher des emplois pour plus de social
et c'est bien sûr mais sur les comptes
publics
on va pas faire semblant on va avoir du
mal pour les 08 année prochaine on va
avoir du mal pour faire entrer ses
impôts qui seront peut-être moins
d'ailleurs parce que justement la
croissance sera pas au rendez vous donc
il faut dire les choses
en revanche sur le reste sur le
collectif sa loi de finances si nous
sommes là et nous sommes bien solidaire
et permettez moi ce petit pot un peu
taquin c'est que quand j'entends le mini
intérieur dire que le droit de vote des
étrangers c'est pas ce qui l'intéresse
pas nous on est là quand j'entends
certains dire le mariage universel ça
doit être un peu pour plus tard sans la
pma alors que le présent république lui
s'était engagé sur la pma bas nous on
est au rendez-vous et limoux sera aussi
au rendez vous pour lutter contre le
cumul des mandats et vous voyez beaucoup
de sujets où nous sommes bien plus
solidaire du dollar ainsi même si ça me
choque pas que ce débat à gauche rem et
jean vincent placé justement sur tous
ces sujets sur le mariage homosexuel et
sur la procréation médicale assistée sur
le droit de vote des étrangers sur le
non cumul des mandats
tous ces rendez vous pris effectivement
par le présent à un public pendant la
campagne présidentielle ont été
repoussés 2014
après les municipales pour le droit de
vote des étrangers par exemple qu'est ce
que c'est
mais aujourd'hui la porte parole du
gouvernement a dit soupçonner ce n'y a
pas de majorité vous le savez bien au
parlement qu'est ce que vous voulez un
référendum non mais moi je veux pas de
référendum parce que je vais vous dire
j'ai toujours dit je vais y compris sur
le pacte budget européen
moi je suis contre la logique référendum
dans notre pays donc j'ai pas de
problème par rapport à ça
mais par exemple le président république
moi je suis là aussi pour l'inciter à
tenir ses engagements
nous nous avons un accord mais la
majorité pour voter
j'ai 35 m il faut qu'on montre dans ce
cas là ça veut dire que à quoi
à quoi ça sert à faire de la politique
si on dit ah bah non là on est sûr que
ça va pas passer donc on fait pas c'est
pas à les envoyer au casse-pipe
non non non je souhaite qu'il y ait une
un engagement ferme dynamique et
volontariste du du chef du gouvernement
pour arriver à faire passer cette
proposition de loi le plus rapidement
possible et au moins au premier
trimestre 2013
et je rappellerai même si moi je suis
pas trop la logique référendaire qu'elle
présidera public s'est engagé les
engagements du président république je
vais vous dire parti socialiste lorsque
ils ont un arbitrage difficile y compris
notre défaveur diavel président public
l'a promis il va très bien
faisons les promesses du président un
public faisons-les sur le droit de vote
des étrangers
faisons le également sur le non cumul
des mandats sont drastiques
faisons-lui 13 voire même plus loin yas
marina
le chef de l'état il y a deux mois non
c'est une émission télévisée a dit on
rendez vous dans deux ans ben moi j'ai
dit tout la même chose depuis le début
par rapport à la participation
gouvernementale écologiste par rapport à
notre soutien il est évidemment acquis
par confiance mais évidemment comme en
amour la politique ce sont des preuves
voilà donc moi l'épreuve j' attends
c'est à dire vous attendez l'épreuve
bien sûr vers vigilant quelques mais non
parce que je n'ai pas dit ça il comprit
il faut mobiliser la société beau faire
en sorte que ce droit de vote des
étrangers il ya une évolution que cette
évolution de la société face pour faire
en sorte que par exemple les élus du
pays
les bastions et jean louis borloo a
moment you were la porte là il est le
reconstruction du pays dont qui
consolide un peu il en interne dont qui
ferme mais c'est un débat qui peut qui
peut évoluer jean mary of lagarde le
député de drancy et pour donc ses
opposants
lui pendant la campagne il soutenait
françois hollande qui les contres dont
les gens compensation il veut favoriser
les naturalisations ça va dans le bon
sens il faut pas s'asseoir en
compensation charles d'irma la question
naturelle et à 0 la naturalisation vous
savez que pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'important donc on peut pas dire ce
soir une compensation ça doit être une
grande politique d'intégration à la
république le présentera comme ça non
mais je sais si si si je crois que
là-dessus sur cette question là lui
aussi
vous savez il n'est pas le pain des
français ça m'intéresse particulièrement
j'en ai beaucoup discuté avec lui il est
d'une sincérité totale et franchement il
n'est pas du tout dans le débat
naturalisation versus pas de droit de
vote des étrangers
ce serait pour le coup méconnaître la
sincérité sur ce sujet de manuel valls
de la vienne et de nombreux
parlementaires de la majorité donc sur
ce sujet là voilà les choses sont dites
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
volontarisme et y en a un qui fait
toujours beaucoup de bruit dans le
gouvernement serre moment voulu je
faisais mais bien le critiquer alors
comment vous avez trouvé sa marinière à
la une du parisien magazine vendredi
dernier je m'étais dit petites phrases
comme ça mais j'ai bon c'est me dire que
si le ridicule tuait encore et bien il y
aurait un remaniement gouvernemental
véhicules propres mais pourtant il a
fait beau hélas il a fait booster les
ventes
céline pour molex mais non mais
franchement
retrouvez quoi c'est même pas ça c'est
que comme tout tout est dans tout aussi
si ça avait été un moment où il y avait
une forme de réussite de son action qui
avait une dynamique et puis qui fait un
petit clin d'oeil sympa mais tout de
même
moi je
j'ai de la mémoire malheureusement pour
certains c'est les discours sur ps1 les
discours sur florange des discours selon
petroplus
moi je m'étais permis parce qu'on m'a
dit à de telles polémiques avec lui j
non j'ai pas de polémique avec lui c'est
que dans trois à quatre mois on sait que
ça va fermer
il faut être sincère c'est le même débat
est tout à l'heure où j'étais un peu
sévère sur certaines commissions il faut
être sincère
on sait qu'on n'a pas de moyens
politiques et financiers
on le sait j'ai dit au ghana on va
nationaliser ces entreprises on va faire
la commande publique l'europe ne permet
pas on va participer au capital on va
renflouer les caisses on le faisait dans
les années 80 ans avec usinor sacilor et
donc moi je sais pas vous voyez les
résultats
il ya eu le débat de l'européenne by
night qui avait été lancé par sarkozy et
qui avait été repris un moment avec le
made in france le lien européenne va y
ait de mediène france pourquoi pas mais
avec quelles dispositions
est-ce qu'il va à bruxelles faire
changer des dispositions pour protéger
notre marché intérieur européen s 10
voilà mais olivia cattan peu choqué par
ses pairs bien sûr là je me dis vraiment
ils se moquent coeur historique du monde
j'espère quand même que y compris par
rapport aux gens de donner aux gens de
florange aux gens que petroplus quand
ils voient ça vous croyez quoi vous
croyez que ça les amuse de voir le
ministre les a beau nous mentez à la
comme ça quand marine et enfin c'est
ridicule voit la dernière question avec
notre partenaire orange et leur
application
tvcheck mbié beaucoup de questions de
militants écolos qui se disent en
général un peu déçu de votre
participation au gouvernement fin de la
partie mais je vais vous poser plutôt la
dernière question qui nous est arrivé de
deux tomes qui lui est séduit par le
discours de borloo et par son nouveau
parti centriste lui dit et nous allons
chantal jouanno qui veut en faire le
premier parti écologiste de france
qu'en pensez vous c'est un peu
antinomique par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
fait pendant cinq ans
il s'avère j'aime beaucoup jean louis
borloo personnellement comme beaucoup il
encore dans la classe politique
je pense il a dit les choses très
clairement il vient de faire déjà ce
rapidement
jean louis borloo il a lancé le grenelle
de l'environnement et madame jouanno et
madame pros jusqu'au morizet eux elles l
ont enterré c'est à dire que après jean
louis borloo ils ont réussi à enterrer
cette belle idée en faisant strictement
rien en obéissant au chef de l'état
sarkozy qui avait dit l'environnement
maintenant ça suffit
et maintenant maintenant il a fait l'udf
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que
giscard d'estaing et simone veil étaient
là c'est qu'il a fait du df un parti
social libéral européen centriste et
donc de droite comme on disait alors
alors vous avez raté la arnaud
montebourg juste un mot sur vincent
peillon qui a repris la proposition de
dépénalisation du cannabis
on se souvient de la polémique avec
cécile duflot vous le trouvez
irresponsable au courageux d'un mot je
le trouve brillant intelligent et
courageux palais en sommes d'ailleurs
marisol touraine comme christiane
taubira comme stéphane le foll
je peux vous dire je peux vous dire que
parce que vous demandez toujours les
critiques et là il y en a par rapport au
projet écologiste mais très globalement
très majoritairement les mini se
trouvant un travail remarquable et
particulièrement en valeur les deux
autres cécile duflot ee pascal canfin
voilà vous connaissez bruno l'effet
ballon c'est merci à vous merci jean
vincent placé
merci pérenne bonsoir à tous
le vrai courage gilles leclair s'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts tout le monde
sait le faire nicolas sarkozy est parti
mais la crise est pas partir la
politique économique du gouvernement
je lui donnerai un zéro pointé tous les
matins à 8 heures 15
guillaume durand et gilles leclair
reçoivent une personnalité politique
dans l'invité politique reconstruire sa
crédibilité
reconstruire sa popularité il faut pas
préjuger on peut juger après en
partenariat avec radio classique
l'invité politique
tous les matins à 8h 15 en direct sur
public sénat
le plus vous manquait d'abord en amour
de la vie politique
j'ai pensé à cette reconversion depuis
très longtemps je me suis préparé et je
voudrais dire que pas grand chose ne va
me manquer de cette vie politique parce
que je vais demeurer une citoyenne qui
s'intéressent qui parle et cetera même
si je n'aurais plus de responsabilités
dans un parti politique
je vais regarder ça avec beaucoup de
liberté parce que justement c'est ça que
je vais retrouver et qui me manquait
dans la vie précédente
cette liberté cette capacité
d'expression est ce que je retrouve me
plaît plus que ce que j'ai perdu
et alors qu'est ce que vous allez le
moins regretté ce que je vais le moins
regretter c'est le fait d'avoir toujours
des gens qui décident de ma vie y
compris ma vie personnelle
vous êtes entouré par des gens
extrêmement dévoués mais qui vous
organise vous surveille
on a quelquefois l'impression d'être un
vase posé sur une étagère comprend ou
des courriers commandés cette voie là
est très conseillé exactement
au même moment au ministère de la
culture frédéric mitterrand accueille
aurélie filippetti une passation aux
allures de festival de cannes empreinte
de la plus grande courtoisie chez lui
souhaite bon courage et les choix une
bonne chance moi je souhaite à frédéric
mitterrand le bonheur aurélie filippetti
découvre ses bureaux de la rue de valois
image singulière d'une ministre
accompagné par sa mère pour sa prise de
fonction elle a fait ses premiers pas
dans les cités minières de lorraine et
elle arrive maintenant sous les ors de
la république
c'est quelque chose très émouvant et
juste autant je suis je crois
légitimement crif hier alors aurélie
filippetti ne parle pas de ses origines
lors de la passation de pouvoirs mais sa
mère est là et donc évidemment elle en
parle pour elle alors c'est un moyen de
faire passer des choses très
personnelles lors de cette cérémonie
protocolaire d'où la question et je me
tourne vers vous de la milda kia les
femmes sont-elles des politiques comme
les autres où sont-elles plus people
dans le people que les autres politiques
alors en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que le people s'intéresse
davantage aux femmes
oui mais si vous en venir sa mère
forcément elle prête bien entendu on a
du mal à imaginer un ministre homme
venant avec sa mère se serait tout de
suite désobligeant pour lui on est
forcément sa maman exactement
donc là c'est une carte qui est joué une
carte de communication politique et
jouer à dessein la part d'aurélie
filippetti et s'introduit nouvelle
dimension plus plus humaine plus proche
et on associe souvent les femmes en
politique avec la gestion du foyer du
foyer familial
du coup sûr ces images vous en pensez
quoi vous de ces images c'est justement
dans ce contexte là c'est c'est bien de
jouer cette carte personnelle où ça peut
être dangereux parce que justement ça
sous-entend qu'elle vont être peut-être
plus dans le registre on va dire de
l'intimé mois dans le registre de la
politique avec un p majuscule si vous
adorez ces deux ris parce qu'on est un
pays qui est appelée extrêmement
politiques ont un pays qui se méfie
énormément de toute la relation entre le
public et le privé et tout ce qui peut
apparaître comme étant l'exposition de
sa vie intime en général est plutôt
malvenu en tout cas n'est pas forcément
perçu positivement ou créer de la
suspicion à l'égard du fond politique
donc
voilà quoi alors si ça peut susciter de
la suspicion sur le fourreau niveau en
tout cas ça peut susciter une petite
interrogation sur la capacité d'aurélie
filippetti est entièrement libre de son
action le fait de feu de faire appel à
sa mère ou à un proche dans des moments
qui sont pas forcément des moments
d'émotion mais qui sont également des
moments politiques ou républicain peut
pour parti fragilisé aurélie filippetti
un petit mot sur ceux là dessus juste
deux choses effectivement moi ce que je
pratique souvent quand je regardais
imhoff quand je lis des écrits peu de
femmes politiques je pratique ce que
j'appelle le test de symétrie si c'était
un homme est ce que ça fonctionnerait
évidemment ça ne fonctionnerait pas
parce qu'on a dit parce que peut-être
qu'un homme se verrait mois invité sa
mère a la sensation de pouvoir ou à
l'armée et voilà ça ne fonctionnerait
pas donc on est là dans la construction
d'une identité de femme spécifiques
alors bien sûr elle abonde ce type de
stéréotypes et les journalistes parce
que je crois qu'il ya aussi un mot à
dire là dessus en jour puisqu'ils
répondent très fortement cette mise en
scène qui est fait par les femmes
politiques parce que journaliste il aime
bien contient plus de people and co
construction qui est atteinte
je demande à tous et notamment aux
socialistes de prendre conscience que
nous avons besoin de se tenir et la
police et la gendarmerie dans ces
quartiers notamment quand on leur tire
dessus parce que ceux qui leur tirent
dessus ne le font pas au nom d'une
révolte ou d'une révolution ils le font
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas que les
forces de l'ordre interviennent dans les
quartiers pour démanteler les trafics
d'armes
les trafics drogue hybride autre
jeunesse et la gauche parce que je ne me
sens pas qu'isolé avec la confiance du
président de la république du premier
ministre de mes collègues au
gouvernement des élus socialistes et
c'est un changement par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu connaître par le passé
la gauche doit rétablir l'ordre
républicain là où il ya un ordre qui est
celui de la junte qui veut chasser la
république de ces quartiers
mais je continuerai à mener le
démantèlement de campements où il ya de
la misère sanitaire sociale il ya des
bidonvilles qui peut permettre à gauche
des bidonvilles dans le vent lieu qui
peut permettre des villes en villes sous
les autoroutes qui peut permettre que
dans le département de la seine saint
denis
sept mille personnes vivent dans des
conditions épouvantables dans un
département qui connaît déjà